seat belt off for me
a wild ride caught on body and dash
camera video shows the suspect behind
the wheel of a stolen Jeep take off with
a Michigan police officer halfway inside
the vehicle
[Music]
the body camera video shows the moment
the suspect speeds off as a police
officer hangs on for dear life fighting
for control of the wheel okay
take your seatbelt off for me yeah take
it off I'm ready
it happened just north of Detroit in
Ferndale Michigan on June 12th an
officer there pulled over a jeep that
was speeding more than 30 miles over the
limit near Eight Mile Road
I could apply to your power rate of
speed westbound Eight Mile laying up now
looks like we're stopping in front of
the Kroger on West State Wyoming and
West State plates gonna be zero eight
eight Mary six three eight zero eight
eight M 638 I'll take another car body
camera
he was later identified as 25 year old
Donald brazell
all right
how are you doing tonight it's a muscle
jelly you know why I'm stopping you uh
part of that Sly back there about to
close
okay yeah you were sliding back there
and then the reason for the speed is
what no reason
their driver's license
this car rental too sir
that's how it's a manufacturer plate so
where's the comeback to uh
the dealership
okay what dealership to come back to
foreign
[Music]
quickly responding officers determined
something is off with brazelle's license
plate and driver's license officials
eventually determined Brazil presented
them with a fake driver's license
license plate and insurance information
and you see that plate doesn't even come
back to this car at all
let's come back to it it's a it's a
dealer plate or whatever yeah it's a
manufacturer plate yeah FCA us else
nothing look
it's a register too
uh FCA yeah so it's Chrysler cars
because it's Chrysler yeah so it's not
going to register to anything it's
because it's a it's a I don't have to go
up and grab I'm gonna have to grab that
VIN this Ops number is not coming back
to him
three three
two
seven zero
North Carolina
this is triple check
this driver's license number comes back
to Jose Alvarez
Jose Andrews Martinez is that a
different guy yeah completely different
let me see this one
this is a fake
that's what it felt like in my hand
because what does that say on his name
Paul Myers why is this as Jonathan
Youngblood the officer then approaches
the vehicle
yo I'm just making sure the VIN matches
up that's it
I'm gonna pop in the door over so I can
see the vinodin got it over there
should be right here on the inside of
the door
[Applause]
it should have been right here where it
should have been right but yeah they
just threw me this way so this is
something I use this okay
gotcha
uh you have the
um
[Applause]
but it's not theirs
how did you shut the car off first
until we get this figured out but it's
when officers approach the Jeep for a
third time that Brazil takes off with
the officer halfway inside the vehicle
all right
for me
dash camera video shows the same moments
from other angles
[Music]
thank you
six points
as Brazil drives off the other
responding officer rushes to his squad
car to follow
six points
[Music]
give us cards
perhaps
[Applause]
dude okay okay okay okay relax hey
bro
come on
you need to relax
all right relax listen
you're up for accelerator
okay
taste me bro get out I'm gonna tase me
bro get out of the car get out okay let
me come on
no you're getting out of the damn car
I'm gonna get out of the car no hey
right now no look at me bro I've got the
car get out get out of the car all right
all right step out of the car all right
all right
I get it bro I get it bro yeah
for what dude for what
if you're all you want anything awesome
fear for my life
hey do me a favor shut up
this is a game dude what the hell is
wrong with you
thank you
they're taking off our photo of the
vehicle
in the vehicle you're playing with us
[Music]
this video shows the entire incident
from the perspective of the officer who
was dragged along for the ride okay all
right you're gonna have to shut the car
off shut the car off for me real quick
don't take off
okay
bro
stop stop we're gonna crash we're gonna
crash relax dude listen relax relax all
right relax relax relax relax relax
relax
okay relax dude relax gotta
well next dude relax
you're gonna get paid relax relax you're
gonna get tased bro relax
awful safe relax okay don't feel safe
you gotta stop you gotta stab you gotta
stop
you gotta stop dude okay okay okay okay
relax
We're not gonna kill you relax
hey I'm out of the car look at me okay
all right relax listen get off get off
the accelerator
step out of the car
all right
yeah you almost killed me
oh for what dude for what
you can fear all you want you don't
think I have some fear for my life
yeah for once a year
hey do me a favor shut up
he's a fun game dude what the hell's
wrong with you
that's cool
is that what it is that's how you're in
you're in a hot car dash camera video
shows part of Brazil's initial search
[Music]
as other First Responders arrived to the
scene the officer describes the incident
him you in the car yeah
I'll start recipe
to check on July
you good yeah
[Applause]
is he the only one
yeah
don't you come back to everything he
gave us a fake ID
hey why don't you just have a seat
yeah and also I don't know okay
let's have the car stolen there's got to
be the bins off it as soon as I point it
out there
officials then search Brazil again
hey you got any weapons on you or
anything like that
car stolen
[Music]
yes Lean Forward
take your shoes off
give me a beat
foreign
ERS arrive on the scene what's up boys
oh I got dragged
it's a good it's good
yeah
me and him were fighting for control of
the car oh yeah yeah I jumped a few
curbs escaped in the parking lot
I don't know I just felt a pop in my I
don't know if I felt to do my knees has
been killing me yeah I don't know what
the hell happened
we're able to move it at all yeah I can
like I can move it I just like I'll try
yeah
I'm a tough cookie dude
[Music]
Wild Ride go ahead officials later
determined Brazil stole the Jeep from a
nearby Township several months ago he
now faces multiple charges for the
assault of a police officer now the
officer who was pulled along for the
ride injured his knee in the incident
but has since returned to work reporting
for long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie